so let me just tell you briefly what
assembly theory is because assembly
theory is actually a kind of a cool way
of actually
doing entropy without labeling and it's
just about
as a chemist i realized years ago
that there are molecules on earth that
are just weird right weird molecules
like really complex and so let's just
take a molecule that i that is used a
lot called taxol taxol is made by the
pacific yew tree it's a metabolism it's
a it's a it's a secondary metabolite
which means it's made by protein
interaction proteins in the cell and
that molecule is really special because
it's very good at um
killing
vascularization of cancer tumors so
people get that and they they they use
it as an anti-cancer drug now to make
this molecule it's like got 62 carbon
atoms you know load of oxygen atoms
nitrogen and so on in this pattern
and this molecule has a molecular weight
of about
852.
something like this someone would go and
check it now it's wrong
it's like okay like i'll google it
whilst i'm saying but it's a big
molecular weight and it's a fingerprint
and the way that molecule works is the
way the combinatorial chemistry works
that molecule
is
beautiful it's like a rembrandt right
it's in its features
but chemists can make loads of it so you
can make literally
um 10 to the 23
6.022 times 10 to the 23 and that's one
mole so you have one mole of taxol so
that's 10 to the 23 identical copies and
that's made in biology on earth human
beings can make it in the lab but
if brian and i did the math together and
we said right we'll look at that
molecule we'll work out what is the
probability that that molecule
could form randomly in a plasma in the
universe
it's basically one in a like countless
in 10 100 right maybe more
that's just for one molecule
so if you find a detectable amount
you're like oh oh my god this is like
the biggest coincidence ever so that's
where assembly theory was born
and i realized that there's lots of
molecules on earth that pass the great
filter they are made by biology and i
realize they can make a detection system
that detects molecules that are above
that threshold of complexity and that
when you do random miliuri and random
stuff
get meteorites and look at the organic
chemistry they're way below that filter
they have an assembly number and what
assembly theory does it says like take
your molecule put it on a graph
what is the shortest route you can get
from your atoms to that target the
shortest possible route how many steps
right so it's a bit like you take the
word abracadabra if you were to make if
you've got a b
uh um you know c r a how many steps
would you need to make the word
abracadabra well you can do it in in a
much number the number of letters in the
in the word because you can reuse some
parts and so my conjecture is assembly
theory says it finds where there's
memory of contingency in a chain so it
looks for lossless compressibility
that's kind of cool right it's a bit
like a information theory compression
shannon
but it's just like that what is the
shortest route to get there because
like brian
i'm as an experimentalist the data is
more important than my feelings that's
right and so you know it's like
so i'm like ben shapiro you just sounded
like ben shapiro for a second
yeah i love ben shapiro
and so
it's really important that we understand
that because
it work it's pervasive right where
people just think that and chemists
think that complex molecules this is
where the chemists
they're getting they're beginning to
change their view
and what i'm trying to say is that the
the chemists don't because they take it
for granted that there's complex
chemistry everyone saying hey guys it's
not just rna that's important atp is
important you know that's my that's my
joke lee i say you know in in economics
you know past performance is no
guarantee of future results it's like we
have past performance evidence here on
earth but
that's no guarantee so assembly theory
what it does it allows you given a
complex molecule you can work out the
likelihood it formed by chance and and
that i think is fairly irrefutable
although publishing that paper last year
took me six goes right i sent it to them
why do you think that is
well because they are well it took me i
sent a nature i almost got in right
senate nature i got three reports back
two said wow one said
can't be right
so i wrote back and and so then they
tried what do we do and i said well
we can ask the referee why it can't be
right so he said i'll do that there and
they're everywhere could say the referee
why can't it be right and the referee
said in the second round
because it's impossible
we're like okay this is like i kid you
not right this is a conversation we had
with the editor i said but here's the
data are you saying we fabricated the
data and the referee just said it's
impossible
and we we went in this loop and what
actually happened is one of the referees
fabricated
a data
from a paper to assert that we couldn't
be right that's how desperate they were
i got the evidence right come back fab
they said in this paper it says that
complexity is important is already
present in outer space blah blah blah
blah
and
and the editor reddit went oh reject
again and when i pointed to the editor
that the referee took the word complex
mixtures have been found in space and
changed it to complex molecules because
they were so believing the complex
molecules are a free lunch
um i then went to the fifth round to
review and the editor by this point was
like just like
go away we're not publishing i said no
we're gonna i believe in the rule of
peer review i'm answering all your
points
this is important it's important we
change people's views of complexity
because brian is on a really good side
we're saying hey i want the data i know
that nothing is for free and the chemist
in the middle saying everything is for
free complexity happens and i'm in the
middle saying no i can count it and
quantify and here it is what actually
happened it was rejected
right because of for i won't go into i
don't want to complain i'm a very lucky
um scientist i love doing the science i
just feel bad for the research group but
i got it published i published in nature
communications and that paper was
downloaded 27 000 times in five months
um because we presented the theory the
mass spec and all the evidence we had a
little meteorites we even got scottish
whiskey we proved that scottish whiskey
is evidence of life because there's
complexity in the peak right we show it
works so we know we can fingerprint life
on earth and molecules um and so it's
but we realized something more that
assembly theory is about just something
about molecules it's about
every time you have a step on your path
and you make a decision let's say you go
down the street and you say i'm gonna go
left today you go left you say right i'm
gonna go left again then i'm gonna go
right and go left and right and you find
yourself in a very particular spot
that contingency is pretty on your
history right there's a lot of
mathematics on that
and we're finding that this is the
the assembly theory that we generate and
i haven't spoken to brian about it
because sarah and i just finishing the
paper and oh my god it works and what i
mean by that i mean that i can take a
kilogram of sand and calculate the
assembly of that kilogram of sand and i
can calculate take a kilogram of e coli
and calculate the assembly assembly is a
number like entropy
an entropy tells you the causal power of
the object
and of course the causal power of a
kilogram of a kilo of e coli is vastly
higher than the kilogram of sand because
the sound can do nothing so what about
the uh assembly of rule 38 wolfram's you
know rule well and
you'll hear about this in a few weeks
maybe but the problem with that is that
is again a labeled system so rule 38
doesn't exist outside of a von neumann
machine and graph paper an observer
putting the rules in so yeah so there's
so the problem is it and physicists get
stuck with things that give complexity
that aren't really complexity it's just
games with numbers
and and i think that i've got a little
bit of work to do with that and i think
the wolfram's ideas here are pretty cool
i think they're not they're not the
problem is with wolfram he traps himself
in a line of thought and doesn't talk to
anyone and think he's the lost genius a
bit like eric actually and no one will
talk to him we'll talk to him in fact
he's got a lot of good ideas that might
actually be right but it's [ __ ] up
i've had not only have i talked to him
and i've talked to eric i've talked to
him and eric at the same time i'm like
oh cool i'd love to take part in that
conversation if i maybe could bang their
heads together
assembly theory tells you about
causation it's now measurable
and that's why i'm excited because we're
going to start to roll this out we'll in
in inanimate objects and it will help
physics i think newton screwed physics
because screw n newton and there's a
hell of a thing to say i'm british right
i love newton you know there's a lot of
coins and on our notes and everything
but leibniz understood assembly theory
and i've been reading philosophy for the
last few weeks if you read the
monadology from leibniz you'll see that
he understood
assembly theory and that objects have
souls
this cup has a soul and you're like okay
there's legal on or pans like you say no
no the soul is not in the cup but it's
in the causal structure of the person
that made it who made it who made it who
made it this cup is a fantastically
improbable object that cannot have
existed at a long line of cup makers
that's where the soul of the cup is okay
let's let brian respond to what you've
said
well you know i think i mean it's
unassailable to say that you know
complexity begets complexity and again
that lee will take on intelligent
designers with one fist but he'll also
you know take on chemists uh with the
other and say look we we have to address
you know as as uh
as uh you know roger penrose calls the
mastodon in the room which is you know
this surprising you know uh feature
about the universe that we can
comprehend it we tend to impose you know
consciousness upon it and our
definitions our contingent upon our
causal history and how we were assembled
you know and i think the ultimate theory
of everything when it comes to what
lee's working on will have to involve
the observer which will undoubtedly then
finally force him to get into
fundamentals of quantum mechanics which
i don't think he can call chemistry i'm
okay with you calling you know entropy
and thermodynamics chemistry but i think
you know the elementary foundations of
quantum mechanics that's a stretch i've
always wanted to be a physicist that's
okay okay yeah well me too but you know
i i lapsed and became an astrophysicist
but i think um
you know when we talk about how uh you
know this this can be used to to kind of
um
as i say be quantitative how we can get
something out of it deliver some value
to the audience uh certainly these are
and the last the more flexible we are i
think the more can be understood but
maybe maybe to even narrow down and come
back to the original definition of
things i think to have a taxonomy you
know what what is it that the the name
is not the thing uh there's there's some
principle like that right um and so so
yes describing things that are complex
and are have originators in a mind that
on the one hand is beautiful it's
elegant it's it's simple and again in a
in a praiseworthy fashion not in a
childless fashion on the other hand i do
think we have to then confront the
ultimate you know question of you know
is there does there have to be some mind
at work behind the cup behind the 747
behind the uh the the dna code and i i
think we know we've agreed not to really
get into this this notion but i think it
at some level we just get to this uh a a
eventual chicken or egg and this mon
bailey you know retreat and i guess you
know
i think i think the ultimate you know uh
the ultimate benefit of this approach is
is that it it gives a plausible scenario
for life to arise from inanimate objects
that's that's an ultimate it's a way to
quantify when something is animate let's
just say or was created by something
adamant um
and i think you know to look at how
we can do better and and maybe go
further into which i think is really
important uh you know is life abundant
and technological i think kurt's
audience appreciates that and i think
you know we haven't spoken so much about
that maybe we can talk about that um you
know how and what could we glean from
the search as a search you know and
where are we going qual vadas you know
where are we going with with the search
is it important is a good use of of
chemist's time of physicist time uh et
cetera to look at these uh reported
unexplained phenomena um can that tell
us something is this something that
interests you and and me and and maybe
you know kurt can can lead us in that
path and and kind of yeah really i mean
we're at a very interesting you know
point in time and a lot of it has to do
with people that kurt's had on the show
and that i've tried to have on my
podcast as well um and i think that you
know kind of the abiogenesis
argument is is you know you've
eloquently described it um i think you
know if we look maybe as kurt as an
impartial observer maybe we could say
like where are you kurt in this
discussion because i think you're a
proxy for your everyday audience how do
we how are you feeling about the
prospects of the ultimate question
life from non-life and then we can talk
about universe from non-universe we can
talk about consciousness from inanimate
matter and we can talk about
technological matter from conscious
matter but um where are you sitting
right now kurt